[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIA SNAIDER: You may have
heard the term API product,
and the first
question that comes up
is, what is an API product?
In this next video, we will
describe the API product
and define the components
that make up the API product.
The API product is
a modern concept
for machine to
machine interaction.
As a product, it has
similar components
to that of a traditional
retail product.
If you build upon the
concept of the API product,
focusing on the
consumer, then you
might end up with a Google
Apigee Edge API product
on the platform
of the same name.
In the next few slides, we will
deconstruct the API product
to help you understand
the approach to design,
build, and deploy on the
Google Apigee platform.
The traditional product has been
around for hundreds of years
and is very easy to understand.
Think of your
purchasing experience
as you shop for just
about any product.
If you are on the market
for a mobile phone,
you know that you can go to
just about any online website
and search for multiple options.
In order to make a
purchasing decision,
you want to read through
a description of the phone
to determine if it has the
features that you want.
You might review the
how-to documentation
so you can understand how
to use it and determine
if you like the user interface.
And of course, you
might look at the price
to ensure that it
fits in your budget.
The key components here
are, one, a description
of the product designed
with the consumer in mind;
number two,
documentation on its use;
and number three,
pricing information.
The same concepts applied
to the traditional product
also apply to the API product.
Now let's deconstruct
the API product.
The API is an asset needed
by the application developer
to access the data required
to build the application.
The API in and of itself
should be easily understood,
and this starts with its design.
We recommend designing
the API with the needs
of the application
developer in mind.
For example, when building a
customer service application,
and the only customer
profile data needed
is the customer's
name and address,
don't send all the rest of
the customer profile data.
Limiting the data to just what
is needed in the application
will improve performance
and limit the exposure
to customer data, a problem
that most corporations are
experiencing today.
Finally, it's not enough
just to have a RESTful API.
The RESTful API
is the first step
in providing easy-to-use APIs,
and your application developers
will thank you for it.
Now take that a step
further and ensure
that your developers are able
to easily access and consume
your APIs.
You will need documentation
that tells the developer how
to get started with the
API by registering for it
and obtaining a key to access
the data enabled by the API.
The three components together--
RESTful API, designed
from the outside
in with the target
developer in mind,
and associated
with documentation
that enables a developer to
quickly understand and use
the API--
is what makes up
the API product.
Now let's talk about the
Apigee Edge API product.
What differentiates
the Apigee Edge API
product is the inclusion
of reusable patterns,
packaging targeted to
an intended audience
and the ability for
application developers
to immediately try it out now
through the Apigee Developer
Portal.
Reusable patterns, such as
standard security, traffic
management, and error
handling, reduce
the complexity and effort
required to build a solution.
The application
developer can focus
on innovating
application features,
rather than worry about
corporate standards.
In fact, your
information security team
will also thank you
once they have confirmed
that the enterprise security
standards are incorporated
by default in the API product.
This minimizes the time to the
developers first Hello World,
provides developers with a
quick win and the confidence
to move forward quickly
with your API product.
Your business leaders
will thank you
for providing them with the
ability to go to market faster.
The Apigee Edge API product--
designed from the outside
in with the application
developers needs in mind,
along with reusable assets
following corporate standards
like security, traffic
management, and error handling,
coupled with documentation for
the developer to get started
quickly and improve
speed to market--
is what puts the Apigee Edge
API product in high demand.
Thanks for your time, and be
sure to watch the next video
to learn about the
API product mindset.